[موسيقى]
في العاشر من يناير عام
1863 احتفالات العاصمه البريطانيه لندن
بافتتاح السكه حديد مترو بوليتان اقدم سكه
حديد في العالم التي كانت بمثابه المقدمه
لانشاء سلاسل مترو الانفاق حول العالم
ونقطه توثيقا لاهم الحلول التاريخيه
لمشكلات الازدحام السكاني فما القصه
بحلول خمسينيات القرن التاسع عشر وصل
الازدحام في لندن لذروته فناقش البرلمان
مجموعه من الحلول قبل منها فكره السكك
الحديديه تحت الارض التي دعمها محامي
المدينه
في عام 1860 تحديدا بدا العمل على السكك
الحديديه باعتماد اساليب تسمى القطعه
والتغطيه اي عن طريق انشاء الفنادق على
طول الشوارع
احتاج العمل على مشروع خط مترو بوليتان
لعامين واحدث اذاعجا كبيرا لحركه النقل
ولسكان المدينه كما تسبب في هدم الكثير من
العماره واخيرا كانت هناك سكه حديديه
بطولي خمسه كيلومترات و600 متر تربط سبعه
محطات رئيسيه بلندن وعلى الرغم من تصاعد
الابخره الكبريتيه الناتجه عن استخدام
قاطرات بخاريه تحرق الفحم فقد قطع المشروع
الجديد سته كيلو مترات من حي بعد
38,000 راكب في يومه الاول فيما استخدمه
تسعه ملايين و700,000 مسافر خلال السنه
الاولى في عام 1866
العمل على خط انفاق خاص باستخدام درع
الانفاق الذي طوره جيم جريسد وهو منتهى
الى تشغيل اول خط سكه حديد كهربائي في عام
1890 في عام
1896 افتتح في بودابست اول مترو في القاره
الاوروبيه واستخدمت فيه سيارات مفرده مع
اعمده للعربات ثم حصلت العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس على اول مترو خاص بها في عام 1900
بفضل جهود المهندس الفرنسي فولجنس في
الولايات المتحده تم انشاء اول خط مترو
انفاق عملي في بوستن بين عامي
و1897 وكان يستخدم في البدايه عربات ترامب
فيما قامت موسكو ببناء نظام المترو في
الثلاثينيات
لاحقا استخدم التكنولوجيا حاسوبيه متقدمه
حيث تم في عام
1971 استخدامها بخط فيكتوريا التابعي لسكه
حديد لندن فيما ان اول نظام نقل سريع
بميزه التحكم عن بعد استخدم بمنطقه خليجي
سان فرانسيسكو في عام
بدورها شهد الثمانينات القرن الماضي
تطورات كبيره بحيث اصبحت العرب مصنوعه من
الالمنيوم الخفيف كما باتت مكيفه كما تم
اطلاقه اول خط سكه حديديه في العاصمه
المصريه في ابريل عام
1989 ليربط المنطقه الصناعيه بالمنطقه
التجاريه بواسطه القاهره وشمال شرقها ووصل
طوله الى 42 كيلو مترا وسبعه امتار
اليوم يوجد مترو الانفاق في الكثير من
الدول حول العالم لكن اليوم العاشر من
يناير لعام
1863 بقي يوما تاريخيا ليس فقط في ذاكره
سكان لندن بل وفي كل مكان تتحرك فيه قاطره
تحت الارض حول العالم
[موسيقى]